et
j'imagine que tu dois partir pour un
voyage dans l'espace
est-ce que tu prendrais la navette russe
où la navette américaine
la petite [ __ ] je prendrais avaient
trait sur la dette américaine
ils ont fait sept morts et deux disparus
dont j'ai la navette américaine alors
maintenant tu dois partir dans la bête
je sais que j'ai passé quatre ans pour
arriver sur marc est ce que tu préfères
partir avec une jolie fille ou un mec
les y'a pas d'autres équipages c'est
l'heure du tout de suite
tu peux faire partir avec une tumeur et
ont parodié quand même pour savoir une
bonne chanson hewitt 7 à 5 dans lesquels
je les filles avec une jolie si donc un
peu ça te dérange pas de passer quatre
ans avec nous en tirerons les
conclusions qu'on veut alors est-ce que
la fille qui préférerait qu'elle soit
blanche noire jaune ou rouge arc en ciel
ont pour voir essentielle c'est que sa
cliente est obligé c'est vraiment avec
un excellent jeu que j'ai carrément avec
un majeur ta choisir entre deux mecs qui
préfère quil geste par juppé des
récoltes question est les deux à la
pompe les de la peinture à l'invers on
te dit voilà maintenant vous avez le
choix pour les dix prochaines années
soit vous n'avez plus de 7 du tout c'est
quand même pas le droit de ne même pas
la fille de la navette spatiale mais
passionnant pas prêt à les attacher lit
enfin jouer a pas de sexe pendant dix
ans c'est à qui son nom n'est plus
maintenant non non je ne peux pas le
faire
même toi même ben quoi c'est sa première
solution ou deuxième solution tu ne
manges plus bas en dix ans c'est dire
nous rit avec des dés sont des piqûres
de machin des trucs qu est ce que tu
peux faire ne pas avoir de sexe ou à
bord de gouffre en disant ah oui elle ce
dimanche avant de 7
voilà pourtant moto à non mais alors il
tente alors de toute façon dans ma tête
qui passait non chose ni au camp vrai je
peux te dire sur moi dans ta tête et
bain pendant dix ans je sais dans ma
tête avant l'accident la tête à la
normale en tout cas avec lui sur l'île
déserte arrive à roissy ya le douanier
couche la valise qu'est ce qui te gêne
le plus qu'ils trouvent à l'intérieur de
la balise mein kampf ou un godemichet a
rien dit ou alors ils se trouvent et
yves des stones de 2,4 hors d'usagé ou
pas
mein kampf à un placement alors les
douaniers pour tous les qu'ils veulent
avant tout les emballeurs vraiment
décevant merde
même s'ils sont antillais j'adore les
antilles et pour finir des stars à
l'année via lé corps de 17 aux mecs te
trompes tu t'aperçois qui 30 qu'est ce
que tu préfères comme vengeance lui nuit
puis crevé les yeux avec une perceuse
électrique
ou alors lui tronçonné le sexe avec une
tronçonneuse électrique qui comme moi
j'ai applaudi il écoutait pas parce que
parce que vraiment eu crève les yeux
qu'une personne que les trans one le
sait que c'est qu'une personne n'aura
vécu pendant cinq ans à des fins
personnelles ses excuses en disant ça
mais qui alors vraiment je pense que ce
soit beaucoup plus tôt costa aborde mais
je pense que j'irai doit pas dépasser ce
cheval et 13
mais je pense avoir je vois l'état
mettra je pense que ce serait vraiment
la plus grande dépendance est une bonne
réponse c'est pas vraiment bouddhiste
partage de dire bon tu as quand même
flirter avec le bouddhisme et puis tu
crois la vainqueure nation oui bon alors
si tu étais un carnet est ce que tu
préfères être interné en jean jean
pierre foucault patrick sabatier où
michel drucker ont ressenti que
l'hépatite et parce qu'elle a vraiment
tous les fils de mais en tout cas écoute
moi je pense pas qu'on puisse comme ça
des cendres de combustion moi je
l'approché des visas des ténors de sa
valeur par plusieurs mamans entre les
trois tout cela répond moi j'ai eu entre
sabatier de rigueur il faut qu il a bien
imaginer ce soit obligatoire c'est un
jeu mais que des gens puissent moi j'ai
de la tendresse pour l'e3 est plus
particulier par ticulièrement pour
sabatier routière c'est plus d'audimat
tolérance et sur le temps et sous test
je ne sais pas la tête et des jambes et
au jeu
alors maintenant la bombe arrive dans 5
minutes ou la radio à matin tech ta
fille tombe arrivés tous les trois la
maison abritant des services
on te dit la bombe va tomber dans cinq
minutes qu'est ce que tu fais pendant
les cinq dernières minutes
comme disait l'inspecteur borel
j'ai pris ces biens qui trouve-t-on prix
si tu as le choix entre se sauver ta
fille autant marie tu sais quoi
pourtant avec ton mari qui pourrait
faire d'autres filles c'est sain et sauf
quand même ta fille sûre